foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar high
throughput qpcr microfluidics technology
with single Plex accuracy for plant and
animal genomics
I am Kaylee Bach with lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by standard biotools
to learn more visit standardbiotools.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker
Naveen ramalingam PhD senior director of
assay development at standard biotools
Naveen you may now begin your
presentation
thanks for the nice introduction
thanks for joining the webinar today my
name is Naveen ramalingam
I'm the senior doctor for asset
development at standard buy tools
so today I'm going to speak about how
one can use a qpcr microfluidics
technology
for plantar animal genomics application
with single Plex accuracy
so the agent for today's meeting I'm
going to start with the introduction to
standard buy tools technology and
product
following that I'll speak about
microfluidics technology and how we
enable
customers to use this for planted animal
genomics
after that I'm going to speak about our
latest real-time High throughput QPR
platform called X9
following that I'll speak about few use
cases both in plant and animal genomics
space
and finally I'm going to open the space
for Q a
so who's standard buy tools so we are
leading life science tools company we
are headquartered at South San Francisco
we have manufacturing sites in Singapore
Canada
we have over 5000 Publications so far
out of which 2000 publication is on by
Mark which is our high throughput qpcr
platform
we are ISO 13485 certified
meaning that all our products are
developed under a quality management
system
so to set the stage uh what is
microfluidics
so in simple definition term it means
manipulation of liquids in small volumes
typically in nanometer ranges
so what you see is one of our
microphotic cartridge
on the left
and you have inlets where you can load
samples and assays
in the center the gray square is where
the action happens
it's very hard to see what's happening
in with the naked eye but if you put it
under the microscope what you see is in
the inset
that there are small Chambers for doing
samples
and there are small Chambers where you
can park your assays and these small
Chambers can be used for doing multiple
biochemical reactions
so what we typically do is uh we take
any biochemical reaction we miniaturize
that on to this kind of microfluidic
cartridges
and that leads to multiple advantages
one is cost savings
because we do reactions in small volumes
we Save A Lot on reagents and enzymes
that's pretty expensive
second it's a simplified High throughput
workflow
we can jam in lot of small reactions
into a small square area
that leads to high throughput nature
where you can test multiple samples or
Assets in one run
and the third is efficient reaction
kinetics again since reactions are done
in small volumes there's a high chance
of enzyme meeting his substrate so the
reaction kinetics is pretty efficient in
this kind of microfluidic devices
so this enables something called
lab ownership
so what you see here is a typical
molecular biology lab
where there are different steps in a
process for example if you're doing a
gene expression you take a RNA you
convert that into C DNA and then you do
a your qpsr assays so there are multiple
steps that happens in this process
and what we do is we take this all these
different steps we integrate and
automate all these steps onto this kind
of microphobic cartridges
and that leads to multiple advantages
the first one is being ease of workflow
automation
so every all these different steps can
be automated on one microfluidic
cartridge
the second is less chance of
contamination uh the way to think about
this is all these Chambers are closed
reactors and they are not exposed to
environment so there's less chance of
any reaction getting contaminated on
this kind of metaphorical devices
and third is since the people have less
chance of interacting with the different
steps on this microfit cartridges
there's less chance of human error
okay so to highlight the power of
microflux and why this is so important
I'm going to talk about a very nice use
case here and this is from Alaska Fish
and games
where they've used our platform uh for
application which is very specific for
sustainability
so what happens is in every in every
year during uh summer uh Salman uh comes
to this Bristol Bay for spawning so
there are close to 38 million types of
salmon that they come to this
Bay for spawning and what happens is
they travel along the bay and there is a
fishing grounds where the boats are
parked and they are waiting for fishing
these Salmons the challenge is the
population has different variety variety
of salmon and there might be a variety
which may be of limited quantity and
there might be a variety which is very
quite abundant in number
so the challenge is not to over Harvest
The Limited species so what they do is
when they travel along this course in a
particular place they take samples and
they genotype the different stocks there
are close to nine different uh stocks
that's part of this salmon
so uh the first important thing is uh
the testing has to be high throughput
nature because you need to genotype
multiple samples in a location
and the second thing is the salmon takes
about a week to reach the fishing
grounds
so time is of essence here because you
need to genotype all these samples and
find out the distribution of population
so that you can inform the fisherman to
go and fish in the right location so
that they don't over harvest the less
abundant population
so on the left what you see is they were
using a 384 well plates to genotype this
salmon before they switch to our
platform and what you see is they in a
typical fishing season they used to use
380 for well plates
and once they made a switch to our
platform what you see on the right the
same amount of data points can be
generated using 54 chips
if you're just wondering these are close
to 0.5 million data points in one
fishing season
so this highlights the power of Michael
Frederick's one you can do very high
throughput nature and second you use
very small volume of your master mixer
so you save a lot on your cost
so it's basically improving the
productivity and sustainability of this
whole
process
so I'm going to shift a bit of gear here
today and try to highlight why
microfridics is superior compared to a
typical 96 well plate that's widely used
for doing a qpcr assets
so what you see here on the left here is
a blade-based PCR which is a 96 will
operate here
so if you are looking at 96 different
targets what you do is you can test I
guess one sample and one sample goes
into one well and you have one assays
looking at that particular sample so you
can do one samples against the 96 probes
in a 96 well plate
there are ways to do multiplexing but
the number of colors that's available in
a platform is limited uh the best you
can do is six colors but beyond that it
becomes very challenging because you
tend to see fluorescence bleed over
where one signal might have an impact
from another fluorescent signal
so uh the plate based uh workflow has
limitations like I mentioned it has
maximum of six probes and the second
important limitation is it's very
difficult to optimize assays uh because
all the the six assets
perform in one uh reaction Cube so if
one acid is not working good it may have
have an impact on the performance of
other assays so the assets are not
independent so they have impact on each
other
and the third thing is you have limited
throughput like 1 96 well plate can do
only one sample
so in summary the traditional
multi-color Multiplex has hard limits
and that's why we come in uh with our
microphilic chip and we try to address
all the challenges that I just mentioned
in the previous slide
so what we do with our microfluidic
cartridges we can test 96 samples
against 96 assays so on the far right
you can see there are small squares that
you can use to load your samples
on the left what you can see is there is
again small inlets where you can load
your probes so what we do is use the
microfluidic cartridge we test each 96
samples I guess 96 assets
so every sample will be asset for 96.
targets
so that leads to over 9000 reactions
from one microphotic cartridge whereas
on the left you get 96 data points
whereas on the on the right you can get
over 9000 qpcr data points from one run
and then next year
important feature is the microfluidic
chip is quite scalable so depending on
your sample and asset needs uh you can
pick different formats of Chip that can
save your reagents as well as your cost
so it's pretty flexible in terms of
samples and acid needs
and uh like I mentioned one uh 96
sorry or one
microfluidic chip is equivalent to 100
of these 96 well plates so essentially
you can crash all this 96 12 plates and
just use one microphilic cartridge to
generate the similar amount of data
points
so next I'm going to speak about how we
enable this Multiplex throughput with a
single Plex accuracy
so what you see here is our microfility
cartridge and I'm showing is four unit
Chambers which is shown in the inset
here where you can see small Chambers
so what we do is uh text take an example
that you have a sample which is shown on
in a tube on the left and you have
multiple pathogens
as shown in these different shapes like
a triangle
circle square or a pentagon the Imagine
these are different pathogens in your
sample and we take the sample and we put
it inside the microphone cartridge and
then we spatially separate these
pathogens into different small Chambers
so we take a sample and we spatially
separate this sample so that we can then
do assets on these small Chambers using
a single color
and that leads to a lot of different
benefits one you can look at
co-infection uh which means you can if
you have samples that's co-infect with
bacteria virus or parasites all these
different pathogens can be acid in one
microfluidic chip now
and the important uh factor is uh it's
also single plaques since we do a
spatial separation we can do single
color uh so we don't have to worry about
the typical limitations that I just
spoke about in a multiplex qpcr
the second important feature is the
dynamic panel content uh since due to
single Plex nature if that is the assets
which doesn't work you can just take and
then swap with a new assay uh that you
have already validated so it's very easy
to add or delete assets on this kind of
panel uh because you don't have to worry
about one assay interfering with the
performance of another assay
the second is a greatly simplified panel
design uh since these assets are done in
single Plex uh you don't have to worry
about the interference which I just
mentioned about the multiplex qpcr
and the third important feature is the
fast panel design which means uh the
assay conversion rate uh most of time
due to single Flex nature most of a
design works in the first uh iteration
so we do have to go and redesign Assets
in a typical Multiplex qpcr
and the best part is you can use your
own Primus and probes so if you already
have assays that you already have uh
validated on a 96 well played uh it's a
plug and play so you can use different
format of assets as well so if you have
tacman assays or cyber green assays so
any of those formats can be used in this
kind of microphotic cartridges
so next I'm going to play a short video
to show how the microfluidic cartridges
work to show how things are done under
the hood so I'm gonna
focus on the center of the chip where
majority of the action happens
so what you see here is the microfitica
cartridge and we load the assets as
shown in the hello here
so either you can use an uh a Channel
pipeter or any standard liquid handling
system should work with this kind of
maturity cartridges uh the size of these
cartridges follows the SBS standard
meaning that any liquid Handler should
be able to load uh samples and Assets in
these kind of multiple cartridges
on the left what you see here is it's
loading the
assays
and once that's done then you load your
samples which is shown on the right here
again this can be done with a liquid
Handler
you load your samples with your
mastermix
in the sample side
and once you load the samples and asset
it goes on to a system called X9 which
loads the samples and assets into the
chamber and what you see here is a
pre-applification chamber where the
samples are pre-amplified for all the
targets and then it loads the assays
from left to right and the samples are
loaded from top to bottom so every
sample will be mixed against each assays
so that's how the Matrix of QP cell is
done and once you mix the samples and
assets in a unique fashion then you
thermocycle the chambers where you can
look at a particular Target either using
attack man assay or a cyber green assays
can be used in this kind of devices
so just to give an idea what goes on to
onto the sample and asset side uh this
is our 96.96 integrated preamp uh chip
uh the 96.96 meaning uh you can load 96
samples against 96 assays
so on the left what you see is the assay
setup what you do is you take 2.5
microliters of your 2x assay mix uh the
concentration is shown here and it can
for different probes if you're doing a
snip assays uh you need uh two colors
for different alleles it can be labeled
with Sam or wig if you're doing a gene
expression it can be just one color
using a fan
and then you uh add your GT Probe Master
mix with your assay on this side which
is 2.5 microliters so in total you make
five microliters of your asset mails out
of which you load four microliters into
this small inlets that's shown on the
left here
on the right you load your sample mix so
what comprises the sample is
2.75 microliters of your genome DNA and
this can be at a lowest concentration
example 2.5 nanograms per microliters
and then you load your preamp Master mix
with that which is one microliters and
then it you also have this uh a pool of
preamp assets that goes on with your
genomic DNA so if you add all these
different volumes it comes out to five
microliters and out of which you again
load only
four microliters into this inlets so
just to uh remind you with this four
microliters that's loaded onto this
Inlet you are getting 96 worth of data
points from that small volume of sample
that's being loaded
so that's very small volume that's being
asset on this microfluidic cartridge
so in summary uh to highlight the power
of micro products on the left you will
see the typical 96 well plate on the
right you see uh the dynamic array IFC
so in terms of number of reactions we
are 100 times more we can regenerate
over 9000 qpcr data points
the second is the QP sir volume uh in a
96 well played people typically run
reactions in microliters volume whereas
we do uh reactions in nanometers volume
which is one thousand fold lower than a
typical 96 World play
and the final important thing is you
save a lot of the pipetting tips uh so
on the left you see uh for every well
you need to spend one uh tip that's 96
times 96. whereas on the right you can
uh you just need to do two times of 96
and then generate over 9000 qpc data
points so you save a lot on your tips
and consumables as well
so with that I will move on to our X9
instrument which is our latest High
throughput QP sub platform that we
recently launched
okay so this is a very highly elegant
platform it's a one system where
customers can load their chip and then
based on the barcode on the chip the
system will show up a particular script
and then all the user
start the Run
all the parameters to run the chip is
it's built in in the script and the
customer don't have to worry about
selecting different parameters on this
kind of system
uh the best thing is it's a high
throughput platform so in a typical
eight hour shift you can generate over
46 000 data points uh in in a typical
eight hour shift
um the second important factor which I
just spoke about in the last couple of
slides you can look at up to 96 targets
with a single Plex accuracy which is
very important uh as opposed to a
multiplex qpcr
next couple of slides I'm going to share
data to show how good is this system so
what you see here is the data on the
Precision of the system so what we did
is we took a gap DH assay we did a 16
point uh two-fold deletion series and
what you see is the the qpcr curve and
if you look at the replicas they are all
on top of each other
the high position for doing gene
expression assays
so in terms of reproducibility what you
see here is we took 96 replicates of a
cdna sample and uh we ran across the
Chip And at a mean CT of 12.4 what you
see is a standard deviation of 0.06
which is pretty tight compared to the
industry standard
so if you remember I mentioned the chips
are quite scalable so depending on your
sample and asset needs you can pick
different formats so this slide
summarizes the different formats of the
chip so we have a chip 48.48 where you
can run 48 samples against 48 assays uh
so in total uh it's 2304 data points
um in the center is the 96.96 IFC which
I spoke about
um uh in a couple of slides before we
also have a format that can do 192
samples against 24 assays
that's 192.24 where in total you can
generate over
4608 data points
next I'm going to move to uh some of the
use case application I'm going to start
with uh planned genomics
so for plant genomics uh if you look at
the different uh areas the first step
starts with the pre-breeding where
typically do typically do a DNA
fingerprinting to identify different
varieties of plant species
the next step is to do a breeding step
where based on a particular snip marker
or a simple sequence repeats people take
different varieties of plants and then
they do a breeding based on a marker
assisted selection
and finally uh there are there's a need
for doing uh quality control and this is
for seed purity testing for a particular
line or variety are also taking a hybrid
purity of seed as well
and the second thing is also for seed
lot testing so in order in order to
qualify a seed lot people generally do a
snip characterization as well and also
pathogen detection so if that is uh
season
people typically screen for these kind
of pathogens in seed samples
so uh what we offer is uh we touch upon
all these different areas for plant
genomics on the left what you see is the
requirement on this number of samples
typically the pre-breeding step it's one
to ten samples because you are trying to
look for larger markers at that step and
once you know what your
need then in the breeding and quality
control steps is typically hundreds to
ten thousand of samples that's typically
being used in those steps
on the right is the assets are actually
inverted like I mentioned in
pre-breeding it's typically over nine
five thousand uh markers whereas when
you go to the breeding stab it's
typically in the range of hundreds and
in quality control it's typically 10 to
20 assays
and uh we try to play in all these
different areas for the high density uh
marker ID we have a sample prep uh
portfolio where we can do NGS sample
prep uh for uh genome-wide Association
studies uh we also call genome
sequencing uh sample prep on our
microphobic cartridge as well
on the bottom if there is a mid or low
density need we have different offerings
one is Snip genotyping using PCR and
second if you have a targeted panel we
can do genotyping by sequencing as well
because we have sample prep uh
capability of this kind of microphotic
devices
we can also do gene expression as well
as copy number variation analysis on
these different chips uh so that is Need
for plant genomics we are able to do
those kind of applications on our
cartridge
so uh so next is to show how we cover
the gamut of different areas on the left
you can see that the the quality control
is typical 10 to 20 and that's a sweet
uh spot for qpcr and our X9 platform uh
fits into that nice place
and the second is the market assisted uh
selection in the center where you
typically look at hundreds to thousand
and uh and these are typically a sample
prep for NGS applications and we are
able to do uh those kind of sample prep
on our microphotic uh
so so uh in terms of NGS workflow uh
I'll briefly touch upon how one can do
sample prep on our microphobic cartridge
um so they start with the extracted DNA
or RNA samples from uh leaves or seeds
and then if you're doing genotyping by
sequencing what you can do is you can
design genotyping by sequencing panels
so we do offer a service uh where you
can let us know the targets and we can
design the assets uh for you and once
you have the assets made then you can
load your samples and assets into your
microfit cartridge and you put it onto
the system that can generate automated
library prep for Illumina platforms
on the high density marker screening we
do have application where we can do a
whole transcriptome sequencing so we
have microphotic cartridge that can
enrich mRNA onto uh onto a chamber and
then the system can automated uh system
can make automated library prep uh for
whole transcriptome analysis
so this is one of the use case from one
of our customer in Korea so what they've
done is they have looked at 192 step
markers for a quantitative trade Locus
they have been looking at Cross Breeding
between a large grain variety this is a
henarium which is a high yield variety
so they have Associated close to 192
snip markers for uh for novel rice
varieties
so uh with that I'm going to touch a
couple of cases in the animal health
space
so so what we can offer in the animal
health spaces for example take an
example where a cow Falls sick
so uh it can be for multiple uh
different reasons the the cow might be
infected with bacteria fungi virus or
nematodes
so what we can do is we can test
multiple pathogens in one test so
there's no need to do any reflex testing
uh because in one test you might be able
to figure out what the power is infected
with
so this is a typical workflow that's
used in Animal Health space so the the
DNS extracted from a variety of sample
types it can be from blood fecal samples
urine or even soil samples uh so once
you extract the DNA again we do provide
custom service for asset design and once
you have the assays then you put your
samples
this is Mike free cartridge and then it
goes on to our X9 real-time PCS system
and we also have a very well
uh user-friendly software that can
analyze uh the presence or absence of
pathogens in these kind of samples
so this is a chip that I spoke about so
you can load either 96 samples on the
right and then you can put your 96
assays and then these are different
format of Chip that I just mentioned in
slides before
the one important thing is with 30
minutes hands on time and the runtime
with 2.5 hours you can generate over uh
9216 data points
and like I mentioned the chip is quite
flexible so depending on your assay
types you can either use a tacman assay
or a Casper asses or any cyber green
asses everything should work on on this
chip
so this is an example from one of our
customer
um in Korea again so what they've done
is they looked at the meat quality uh
for uh for uh bovine here so they have
looked at the multiple snip markers and
they try to identify Snips that looks at
uh the meat ratio looking at back fat
thickness and that defines the quality
of the meat and also quantity as well
and they were able to identify uh unique
snip markers uh that's tied up to the
meat quality
so next couple of example is on pathogen
screening in
um
animals the first one is from uh
University of Copenhagen so in this
particular
publication what they've done is they've
screened for 11 different bacteria and
virus in
bovine samples so they've used nasal
swabs as well as fecal samples from cows
and they have screened for multiple
pathogens the target genes are shown in
the center of the slide and one
important thing to note in the
publication is they have highlighted
that after they implemented our platform
they were able to save on the cost as
well as time also remember that you save
a lot on Manpower as well as savings on
consumables
the final example is for porcine samples
again this is from University of
Copenhagen where the views the panel of
pathogens including bacterial virus and
they've screened your samples using
coral fluid as well as nasal swabs from
pigs and they have simultaneously looked
at 18 different uh pathogens which is
shown on the bottom left
so again the reason why they use their
platform is for cost savings and as well
as savings for human Manpower
so uh in conclusion the microfluidics
QPS technology allows massive parallel
reaction with a single color with single
Plex accuracy
I hope I try to convince you guys that
the technology is able to address all
the challenges that's typically
associated with microflix with a
multiplex qpcr
the administration leads to cost savings
simplified High throughput workflow as
well as efficient reaction kinetics
and with regards to use cases I've shown
that the microflix cube is a technology
has been used for seed purity testing
marker assisted selection for plant
genomics as well as pathogen screening
for animal genomics
with that I'm happy to take any
questions
thank you
well thank you Naveen for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for all right so let's get started
our first question here asks what is the
sensitivity of the system and is it
comparable to traditional plate based
methods
yes uh sure
so um we have implemented the covid-19
test onto our microfluidic platform we
also got FDA authorization for such a
test
and for that particular test our limit
of detection was uh 0.125 copies per
microliters
um which is pretty good compared to
other tests that was there in the market
uh with regards to comparison to a
traditional based uh methods using a
plate or other QPS system we have good
number of Publications comparing both
the platforms from our customers and the
data is on par with a typical
qpcr system in the market
thank you another question we have here
asks can you detect DNA and RNA viruses
in one workflow
yes that's definitely possible so in one
workflow what you can do is you can have
the sample go through a reverse
transcriptions tab during that step the
DNA will just stay in the sample and
then once you have the RNA converted
into the cdna then you can ask say for
both genomic DNA as well as cdna with
different assays so we have done that in
our uh
workflow and we have data to show that
we are able to do both DNA and RNA in
the same workflow
great next question is a two-part
question and this question asks what is
sample input requirement for NGS Library
prep and what would the library prep
workflow be
yeah so for uh the whole transcriptome
um application the sample input
requirement is 10 to 100 nanograms of
total RNA
with regards to workflow we have two
different formats of process one like I
mentioned uh it's for whole
transcriptorm and second if you have
targeted panels uh we can do amplicon
based sequencing as well so we have two
different workflows for uh the whole
transcript of what we do is we have a
bead based column onto the chip which
can capture uh poly a mRNA and then you
can wash off all the remaining uh stuff
and then once you capture the MRNA then
you can do a reverse transcription and
then you can do a whole transcriptome
amplification on the chip the good thing
about the the workflow is samples can be
barcoded on the chip so once it comes
out of the chip you can just pull a
clean up and then you can put it onto
the sequencer so that is for the whole
transcriptome application for the
targeted panels again you can give us
the targets and we can design in assays
with the
overlaps that can be used to do a
library prep for uh targeted amplicons
so we have both the formats that goes
onto our chip
next question asks how easy is it to
manually load the chip
[Music]
yeah I think that's a very good question
so if you look at the cartridge of the
chip I when you look for the first time
it may look very daunting uh but if you
are very used to using a a channel
pipeter uh then it's pretty easy then
once you get a hang of it then it's
pretty easy I would like to say that
most of our customers they prefer to use
a channel by Twitter to load the Sampson
assays but having said that we have also
automated loading we have a app node
from Integra biosensors uh recently that
they can use their liquid handling
system to load sample 7 assays and on
top of that uh most of our customers
have also
implemented scripts in uh in platforms
like Hamilton deacons and all other
liquid handling system to load samples
and assets onto this kind of uh fighting
for the coverage
great
our next question here asks does it
support customized pathogen detection in
our samples
yeah definitely I think I did mention
that we do offer a service to design new
assays so if you have some
pathogens that's pretty unique for you
guys we can definitely design assays and
Implement on our chip so like I
mentioned the way to think this is kind
of an open platform uh so any asset that
you already have it working in your lab
or any asset that you need both can be
implemented in these uh microflague
device
great thank you
next question here what is the approach
approximate
um purchase price of the X9 cartridges
so I think that's something it's pretty
variable it depends on the the samples
and asset throughput needs I would
probably uh reach out to the customer
and we can talk with our marketing folks
great I have another question in regards
to price and regarding implementing the
system for phytosanitary applications
and cost of assay creation service
yeah again so uh that the cost actually
depends on the number of assays and how
difficult it's to design those kind of
assays uh so after this meeting we can
definitely reach out to that particular
customer and work with them on the cost
and how much will it cost to implement
this system
great thank you
we've time for a few more questions here
so I'm going to ask this next one you
mentioned that one can also perform
whole genome sequencing using ifcs and
can you please elaborate a bit more on
this
yeah so the whole uh genome sequencing
is more for a single cell application so
we have a
chip that can do whole genome
amplification from single cells and then
from there you can make Library prep out
of that and then you can do a sequencing
uh so it's more tuned for a single cell
application
great thank you Naveen it looks like we
have time for one more question here so
I'm going to wrap up with this one and
this question says I've used a qpcr tool
that only requires a total reaction of
one microliter if I'm not mistaken the
equipment is made in Korea and the
company lent it to the lab at bogor
agricultural University my question is
is the working principle of the tool the
same and what makes this tool different
and
and it's microfluidic system
okay I'm not very sure on the system
that's being mentioned here with regards
to one microliters but what I can say is
uh if there is a system like that how we
might be different is uh we take that uh
sample and we split into multiple small
reactions so we can assay more targets
per sample so that's that's why probably
we might be differing but I have no idea
of what the system is about so again we
can reach out to that customer and talk
to them yeah
wonderful
we're going to go ahead and wrap up
there today so thank you Naveen again
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor standard biotools
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
labyrinths will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye